[Music]
who funds our politics and our
politicians it's a question that's hung
over Westminster for Generations
shouldn't 10 please be banned from
having second jobs duck houses and moats
you couldn't make it up
and one that's never been easy to answer
enough is enough we know the rules were
broken money and Scandal have long been
part of the fabric of our politics I
wouldn't hesitate to do it again
tomorrow but once they're over the
answer is always the same we are going
to hold MPS to account we need a totally
transparent system promise after promise
of transparency but little real progress
until now as we open westminster's
accounts and make them accessible to
everyone
foreign
who is giving what to MPS which
politicians earn the most how does
business try and get its way we took
data from Parliament records the
register of members Financial interests
and the Electoral commission to present
a fuller picture than ever before of
outside earnings or second jobs gifts
and donations to MPS as well as
donations to political parties for
decades all of this information was
clouded in a peak language and filed
away in Dusty tomes in shelves in
Westminster
Sky News and our partners tortoise media
have been working to change that so we
can all follow the flow of money through
our political system now turning
thousands of confusing written entries
into a database available at the touch
of a button allowing us to tell stories
like we never could before like this
over 17 million pounds that's the total
amount of outside earnings the MPS have
declared in the course of this
Parliament just three years and it's on
top of their annual 84 000 pound salary
and this might be one reason why reform
is so hard when a Tory government's in
number 10 of the 17 million 15 million
pounds in earnings made by MPS goes to
conservatives now for the first time we
can sort MPS in order of what they make
from second jobs and other outside
earnings this here is the leaderboard
these people the top 20 made close to
two-thirds of all the outside earnings
in this Parliament again it's dominated
by conservatives 17 of the top 20 are
Tory MPS the person at the top of this
list is familiar to everyone it's former
prime minister Theresa May declaring
over two and a half million pounds life
Post Number 10 appears to have been
treating her well either my right
honorable friend had not read the rules
or didn't understand what they meant and
others around him or they didn't think
the rules applied to number 10 which was
it
this is what the former prime minister
wants you to see out of office but still
upholding standards and holding her
successes to account but away from the
commons are packed a lucrative schedule
since leaving number 10 Mrs May has
earned 10 times her MP's salary giving
dozens of speeches to a host of
different audiences from American Banks
to the Danish legal profession a hundred
and thirteen thousand pounds for a
speech to a scientific conference 136
000 pounds for an address to the World
Knowledge Forum a former prime minister
in huge demand even in countries which
she took on as prime minister
it was the murder of activist and
journalist Jamal khashoggi in 2018 that
made Theresa May a firm critic of Saudi
Arabia I can update the house that no
minister or official is attending the
investment conference in Saudi Arabia as
well as demanding answers she blocked
her ministers from visiting the country
for a conference
four years on and a very different
approach it seems the rich diversity of
cultures religions and beliefs the
former pm on stage herself in the
capital of Saudi Arabia at a travel
conference telling the audience it was a
pleasure to be in Riyadh and being paid
107
000 pounds
for almost two months Sky News has been
trying to get Theresa May to talk about
her outside earnings her office
acknowledges receipt of our questions
but the promised reply never comes this
is Theresa May's constituency office
we're just going to knock on the door
we went on a Friday when MPS are
typically in their constituencies to get
answers that way but no luck it is a
shame that Theresa May isn't here
because she says that the money that she
earns goes into this a company called
the office of Theresa May limited here
are the accounts and that she pays
herself a salary of 85 000 pounds a year
from this company and the rest of the
cash goes to support her charitable work
and to pay for other activities as a
former prime minister but looking at
these accounts is just not quite clear
how that works the cash seems to come
into this company but it's not clear
where it goes from there and now we
can't ask Theresa May what's going on we
know Theresa May is involved in
charitable work but under this system we
just can't see how much or where the
money goes
her maidenhead constituent willing to
make up their mind without the answers
my God that's a lot of money
so I I think if she's more focused on
doing that than being a teacher MP
certainly will affect it MP should be
doing that doing their job not getting
involved in all these other things you
know are you surprised people pay a lot
of money to hear her speak
yeah that's what I'm surprised about
Theresa May she doesn't know what's
happening in maidenhead some are more
supportive it all depends what she's
talking about if somebody wants to pay
money to her who's to sing why not it's
not just the former prime minister who's
been declaring she's earning big sums on
top of her day job Sir Jeffrey Cox is a
second MP that has declared they topped
two million pounds already earned in
this Parliament he's coming from legal
work he says his experience as a
practicing Barrister is invaluable to
politics and he spends no more time than
a cabinet minister would on their job
flying up this leaderboard another
former prime minister Boris Johnson
since his resignation he's become an
earnings Juggernaut he walked out of
number 10 in September and has already
earned over a million pounds he's hit
that total with his earnings from just
four speeches
for a single speech in New York he was
paid at a rate of 32 and a half thousand
pounds per hour that's more than the
starting salary for a British nurse over
a whole year earned in just 60 Minutes
work Liz truss still hundreds of places
below both her predecessors her earnings
total under a thousand pounds royalties
for a decade old book also in the top
five the former head of Margaret
Thatcher's policy unit and former
cabinet minister John Redwood making big
money with a big job title as well as
being MP for wokingham he's the chief
Global strategist for the investment
firm Charles Stanley declaring earnings
of nearly 700
000 pounds from the company since the
last election here praising the growth
of video conferencing because it means
he can do more for the firm someone who
is obviously part-time
I think I'm far more efficient as a
result of these changes because I can
for example break off today and and
share a conference with you for for an
hour at four o'clock in the afternoon
uh whereas I wouldn't necessarily be
able to do that if I had to travel an
hour or two hours to get to a given
venue or an office so I can actually do
more Shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy has been a busy man he lists more
sources of outside income than any other
MP receiving money from over three dozen
separate companies speaking to voters
yes but declaring significant earnings
at the same time David Lanny sits at
kierstama's top table Shadow foreign
secretary for over a year one of the
biggest jobs in the shadow cabinet at a
time of international crisis Mr Lammy
has juggled that role with a range of
outside work a radio show speeches and
training courses for corporations
a lengthy section on his personal
website promotes his skills as a paid
public speaker on a broad sweep of
different topics we're certainly living
in uncertain times from crisis
management if America Retreats from the
world to U.S politics and companies have
clearly been taking notice David Lammy
has listed at least 30 speaking and
training engagements since December 2019
worth around a hundred thousand pounds
as well as more than 87 000 pounds for a
radio program on LBC
all of this hard to square with the
labor leaders firm line against second
jobs ban all second jobs for MPS
with very limited exceptions neither
case dharma's team nor David lamis were
able or willing to set out if his
outside work would qualify for an
exemption from the ban I'm on a
political show putting political views
and putting the views of my constituents
Mr Lemmy's office acknowledge receipt of
our questions but chose not to respond
Mr Lammy has however made an impression
defense of his second jobs on his radio
show why am I here why am I pleased to
be here because one I'm the only black
presenter on LBC
it's important for my constituents I
love the fact that they approach me and
they can hear me putting views that they
agree with out there into the public
some of his Tottenham constituents like
having a visible local MP I think he's
focused enough on the job of being a
politician yeah and I think you think
he's focusing up on Tottenham even
though he's
making all this money outside yeah
just because he's accessible which is
which I think is you know it can't be
can't be said of lots of others for some
constituents it's not the radio show
that's the problem
Lloyds of London JP Morgan Chase Canary
Wharf group GSK some of those are quite
shocking uh to me ask why he did them I
guess and
you know does he agree with the
practices or the values of these
companies I think if that was brought up
for me I'd make me squirm a bit probably
and rightly so all allowed under the
rules which permit MPS to do almost any
second job apart from lobbying MPS
themselves often point out it's no
different from being a cabinet minister
but this is an admission that for some
being an MP is not necessarily a
full-time occupation
coming up with a single easily
comparable figure for outside earnings
unlikely to go down well with MPS who
could have done it themselves there's no
incentive for MPS really to make it easy
to do the sort of comparison that you've
done in this exercise it's much easier
for them to say we've been transparent
the data is out there people can go and
look for it if they want to but in fact
that data isn't very easy to use and
it's not real transparency
MP's earnings information is just one
benefit of the new public tools Sky News
has commissioned from tortoise media
more than half a million different
pieces of data about your MP and all MPS
now able to be explored by anyone
tomorrow we look at donations more
findings more League tables only
possible because of the Westminster
accounts project and these prompt the
question does what MPS tell us give us
the whole picture